[Music]
in desperate times news submitted by
Megan that says hi hey a city in Kansas
is offering people up to 15k to relocate
their [ __ ] no that's how bad that town
is Dean Cain deployed by a mansion in
Kansas for 15k with that kind of money
though it probably got free real estate
too
you just gotta pay the taxes can we go
on killing people out there I'm not
about it we go on Kansas Zillow until at
your house Carson what we do here
they're trying to pay you to live there
for a reason yeah well what's the cost
to live in what else is going on around
there like what's going on what's the C
it does sound like the beginning of a
movie do they have tornado horror yeah
so this city is about an hour's drive
from Kansas City
so it's Topeka and it's part of this
whole thing it's on the Kansas side I
know it took pika
do so then um cuz it Kansas City Kansas
it's not gonna pay money for you to live
outside of Kansas yeah just in the
Kansas side don't let the glasses fall
you focus is it jumping in Kansas it
actually is yeah all right so he was on
his phone while we were filming sorry
sure you would so this is part of this
campaign called choose Topeka and they
are matching incentives between
employers and the joint economic
development organization or jet oh dude
oh that's jet Oh to your channel to
encourage workers to move so gentle yeah
yeah so they're saying that these
incentives will be awarded after
candidates have lived in the area for
one year I was about to say can you go
get the money and jet right and they're
saying that it will be ten thousand
dollars for renters and fifteen thousand
dollars for people who buy or
rehabilitate a home okay okay yeah what
if you oh wow so that's a good idea for
a flipper yes
I'm thinking the same thing what did you
go get the money to be a billion Airbnb
that [ __ ] has to be a primary residence
- yeah yeah but you they don't need to
know this is a lot of time to spend for
15 grand it is a lot of work yeah well
you probably end up with like $1500 yeah
and you gotta sell the house work you
did yeah yeah I mean if you flip it
really nicely though it could turn a
profit true if you're just renting a
place there though that's basically free
rent
cuz I'm assuming like it's gotta be like
$900 a month right for a year
that's really good in Kansas baby we
look at digital what if you live in
Missouri it's just it's your neighbor I
knew people that lived in Missouri and
it was [ __ ] horrible well maybe not
for Missouri right Jim
I like Missouri a lot of nature my
sister went to Kansas State University
and Kansas's Kansas is pretty dope I've
been to Kansas a few times to do
stand-up it's not terrible I just don't
like cold places I don't like you know
that's that's clown boy it was just like
a lot of trees well what's Topeka like
desert space looks very metropolitan
oh you don't I wish that that looks like
every other city things like this they
just need to be honest right it needs to
be like yo please come to throw pika man
what did literally campaign to so be but
I'm saying be a little more honest about
like by [ __ ] me people man please
don't peek our city's dying you should
have the merit how that about how does
that okay so so if I'm correct then you
go move there and then what they're
basically doing is they're taking your
tax money and they're probably keeping
it in an account and then giving it back
to you at the end of the year because
that's probably what it is it's like an
investment so the more heads that they
have the more taxes they can collect in
the future it's like when people get
refund checks yeah and they're like this
is so sick and it's like how's your
money man it was your money
you actually overpaid the government and
everything like that even out in the air
so they're saying that be incentive
funds
yeah I had to burp sorry the the funds
are available for between 40 and
stayed new resident workers oh um in
2020 which are used up already but
they're saying that the 2021 budget has
already been approved so that could be
another if you lived in Topeka already
what you do is you move you pretend to
move out it'll be good you know I mean
we're trying to move out you know and
then like you know you get that money
you know you know this is a small time
one knows everyone you know what this is
like this is like this is like when like
you're already you're on Verizon and
then like you've had Verizon and then
all of a sudden they're like we're gonna
give you three new iPhones and like you
know you like hey [ __ ] what about me
yeah I'm already living in your [ __ ]
town why don't you give me some money
don't you how they hate their customers
you ever try to call Verizon help or
anything no I'm t-mobile they're all
this thing yeah exactly so the median
gross rent until pica is seven hundred
and fifty one dollars
let's go like a duplex we can all live
together quite not as much traffic do we
can't buy our own homes because they're
saying no I want to live with you guys
Street so the median value of a home is
a hundred thousand four hundred what is
that like seven bedrooms and [ __ ] three
wakers yeah that's a one-bedroom the
estimated population of 125,000 904 was
down nearly 2,000 people as compared to
April of 2010 well what's going on in
this city then people are trying to get
out of there
stranger things attractions are evil
knievel Museum Brown versus Board of
Education National Historic for racism
phone and Lake Shawnee dance a limit
there's a lake there do they need to
arcade or some like wow I like nature is
there bowling alley Utley we have know
what there's museums and breweries well
they're trying to encourage people to
come in like maybe open businesses and
the wrong branding cuz they're like you
know what you don't have in the city
space nature mm calmness they need to
make something like you know we got the
world's biggest hole maybe you should
get up with a Marketing Board and
they're losing real estate to move
people in if they have to make room for
this [ __ ] hole what about the world's
smallest marble won't smallest marble
what you guys can't even see it yeah
electron microscope we're doing that
nothing can wow people anymore getting
you interested I like the lake okay we
got strippers with the world's smallest
titties I don't care about the lace
that's just nipples I see maybe I am bad
at this okay yeah you're pretty bad yeah
you're off the board yes smallest oh yes
so they're saying that choose took Pecos
just ribs I just picked your ribs and
nipples 12-pack I picture concave oh
that's why I lost my job in marketing
you need a big little teeny little
littlest titties but I'm saying are you
like a titty guy well if she has to have
titty uh I'm nice guy for sure me too
no more gotta [ __ ] I like duck I don't
my little titties guess what he he loved
big old
[Laughter]
Casey is smiling no dude he sees a teeny
guy he's over there and he's smile like
this and he's just smack himself inside
of the head that's what he did that's
your hand seconds you're right there
true some guys are like some guys are
like no you know my friends are like she
don't got no ass oh she don't got though
so if you're an ass guy titty guy
I've noticed though in nature for some
reason either chicks have boobs or that
have an ass and sometimes they have both
right but like in nature for some reason
evolutionarily chicks do develop
something dope which is pretty cool like
every chick has one dope thing either
asper titties I've seen some that were
very [ __ ] done I've seen big girls do
that and no butt and I'm like how is
your love handles bigger than your butt
it goes over your hips like a side titty
dad there's no ass those chicks does
have more work to do doubt that was I
was like God was [ __ ] up - your work -
dude that's [ __ ] up gotta give him
Pilates I mean you could build an ass I
wish he was an old man right now on the
bench he's there I saw one girl she had
more on the sides as you suggest you get
on the back yep I guess in Kansas right
now this is the conversation about
titties in Kansas the only other so
we're not gonna talk about the brown you
see you talk about the lake look a tad
Evel Knievel alone I don't care about
him I came up the lake I want to go
fishing that's what I want to do this
town this is sad cuz we I can't think of
a reason to tell people to take this
money yeah boy they're not pretty bored
yeah but there's no reason to take this
money like like that's not even an
incentive what could even do is 15 games
until pika anyway you're going to the
museum again at $700 a month that's 15
Wow what's a human anymore fun here's a
rip we're thinking of La Minds though
you got to think like that area right
you got Kansas you got Missouri
you got life what is it Oklahoma or no
Brad
matter yes I hate clubs ooh what I would
like to party the other night and I felt
like like so old it was just like they
were having this like wrap party for
this like Internet company and then you
know I go I'm just like my buddy owns it
and I'm just saying what the [ __ ] am i
doing
they got bottle service launch yeah it
was just crazy I couldn't hear I can't I
can't stand being in a place where I
can't hear [ __ ] got one of those shots
that come through like a Ice Cube sign
you didn't go through all the whole
thing it comes out like that
no it was just it was just like upstairs
in a bar and it's like people to
recognize me in their town obviously
they're being like oh man I'm just going
like this yeah yeah yeah okay let me get
out of here I'm too old for this
there's like holla did you like it when
you were young though cuz I didn't like
you know I've never liked old things I
ever liked being at clubs I never like
drink I don't drink it oh you don't
drink that's also big - yeah I don't
drink either the club should go over
here is Funk
yeah you wish to love club club service
[ __ ] yeah this could make a lot of
money yeah that's crazy they got
business cards ooh [ __ ] yeah oh man I
was in Vegas and it's girls there's the
biggest ones I'm talking about they
could make like $240,000 a year do or
like make it like 20 G's a month yeah
but it only laughs like it it only lasts
one like 2021 to like 24 you know then
they're then they've hopefully they save
their money cuz it cost 10 G's to buy at
the table and then every drink comes in
so you got the people represented yeah
and dude every [ __ ] bottle of vodka
you get like other thing that Smirnoff
it's like $400 yeah there's people that
go in there and they spend like $150,000
in a night and these women are getting
like three to five percent of that those
are working like 10:20
with the to those like like this is what
happens to I think they want to leave
that business all the time because if
you're a guy spending $150,000 and this
beautiful woman's job is to like like
you know pip you out of money you ain't
treating her like she's not she's not
getting respect yeah yeah these guys
aren't treating you like they're
treating you like a piece of like
whatever you know to me grabbing their
asses and me you know being all bossy
and [ __ ] like that so after a while that
money's not worth it true did you hear
what the NFL player he's a rookie and
they do this all time but he's a rookie
he goes to dinner with the team and as a
hazing ritual they order a bunch of
[ __ ] Wagyu beef and [ __ ] and like
Hennessy and [ __ ] and then he has to pay
for it it was a ten ten thousand dollar
bill that's funny
and after tip it's it's twelve grand so
that means the waiter made [ __ ] two
g's just from that table that night some
say that's what this bottle service [ __ ]
you know at these big-time clubs people
dumb idiots going there you know
flossing with their money
you know what's free though the lake
that's why you go to Topeka
[Music]